welcome to Rimes city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct
if you are anything like your downer I
remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me
it has been so long they tried to talk
to me all the time all they hear is pika
pika you can hear him right guys
adorable you're adorable they can't
understand me kiss you no one else here
I don't need a Pokemon period and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic
key is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you